hey youtubers it's Charlie so exciting
news about flash season 3 crank us and
confirmed the episode 1 is going to be
titled flashpoint no surprise but very
exciting there was this funny exchange
between him and greg berlanti who's kind
of like the overlord producer of all
these DC TV shows and he was like I've
read the script for episode 1 it's gonna
be amazing but I can't tell you guys
anything about it yet and then Greg
Berlanti
you know maybe this was playing maybe it
wasn't planned was just like it's okay
you could totally tell them and so Grant
Gustin says episode one is called
flashpoint and then he followed up with
yes you know I've read the comic book
story I've seen the animated movie we're
gonna do our own version it's gonna be
really cool so that's kind of what we
expected it's not like they're gonna
bring Thomas Wayne on they're not gonna
have Wonder Woman on the flash TV show
so when the flash TV show says it's
doing flashpoint it's really pulling the
themes of flashpoint and some of the big
twists out but it's not going to be
doing exactly the same comic book story
it's just like in previous seasons where
villains like zoom end up being a
combination of a couple different comic
book characters or they have this crisis
on Infinite Earths storyline during the
finale where it's just like a small part
of that matically where barry sacrifices
his life to save his friends in the
universe so what is that gonna look like
an episode one though well episode one
will largely be the follow-up like what
happens as a results of Barry saving his
mother he'll come back to a future
that's dramatically different so you can
imagine the WTF reaction the Barry's
gonna have when things aren't the way he
expected it'll just be him reacting and
then adjusting to all the changes so
it'll be really terrifying but it'll
also be really funny they will probably
take every opportunity to have funny
moments in the really cool thing is this
is an opportunity to bring back Captain
cold as citizen cold so if you didn't
read flashpoint from the comics as part
of this alternate timeline Captain Cold
becomes a good person upstanding member
of the community like a traditional hero
would and he's called citizen cold
instead of being called captain cold
he's even in a relationship with Iris
West so that's how different things are
but the big twist of the flashpoint
comic book storyline is that the heroes
end up fighting each other factions
develop people inside the Justice League
end up on opposite sides everyone ends
up destroying each other the world
pretty much ends in this giant nuclear
metahuman apocalypse
so the flash TV show is probably not
going to be that cynical it's gonna be a
slightly more fun version of that but it
does provide opportunities to bring
people back like Eddie
well properly actually see Eddie come on
the show he was more of an easter egg
during season two like he was a name on
the phone yes I totally think that Eddie
is gonna come back on the TV show I
don't think he's gonna be the big bad
though but the interesting thing that
people are talking about now though is
that at the end of the flashpoint
storyline the flash fixes his mistake
but in fixing the timeline they T up the
new 52 so people are like does that mean
they're doing the new 52 on the flash TV
show no absolutely not
they're just doing this flashpoint
storyline where Barry changes the past
dramatically alters the future and then
has to deal with that and either try to
fix it or learn to live with it like
that'll be the big conflict does he give
up his mother because presumably she'll
be alive in modern day so does he give
that up to get back some of the things
that he'll lose from the previous
timeline so I'm interested to see what
he loses in the future like what what
relationships end up shifting because
that's the easiest thing for a TV show
to do is just kind of shuffle the
relationships so like people that were
his best friends before might not be as
close to him iris might not care about
him as much just expect it to look
different than from the alternate life
you saw him have on earth too so it's
not like they're gonna reboot the
universe and he's gonna be earth to
Barry who's married to Iris
so most if not all of the main cast is
coming back but just expect the dynamics
between those characters to be
dramatically different in a like a
really fun exciting way but really the
other exciting thing is that they can
bring dead characters back and fun and
exciting ways like the way they brought
Deadshot on to earth to like oh my god
we thought you were dead on earth one
and you're the bumbling police captain
so I just mentioned earth 2 what about
the multiverse are we gonna go to other
Earth's we've developed earth to like
they spent a lot of time developing
those characters we'll probably see them
again at a certain point the other
earths that we know we'll see will be
supergirls earth because presumably
she's still gonna be off on her own
planet somewhere else in the multiverse
then we have jay garrick's earth they
might try to combine those just for
simplicity's sake and just say they both
come from earth 3 but i would like to
see a Hitchhiker's Guide to the
multiverse Cisco episode where he gets
lost somewhere in the multiverse well
you know without
having to build sets for up like ten
different earths Cisco's ability is like
the path to the flash TV show having a
holodeck so if you've ever watched a
holodeck episode of Star Trek the
holodeck itself is this really amazing
narrative device that they can use to
have a lot of fun let off a little bit
of steam when things get too crazy so
like if the main plotline of the flash
gets like way too serious and crazy they
can always have a fun holodeck type
episode where the characters are in a
different situation for a single episode
so yeah even though Cisco's gonna be
different because of flashpoint I still
think he'll be playing with his powers
in season 3 I would really like to see a
Hitchhiker's Guide to the multiverse so
if you don't know what Hitchhiker's
Guide to the galaxy is be sure to check
the movie out if you haven't read the
book the book is really awesome too but
sometimes it's a little bit easier to
just watch the movie
but I feel like those holodeck type
multiverse episodes are just slam dunks
for the flash every time it does them so
any way that it could find to do those
more but sometimes it can be kind of
expensive to produce because you have a
bunch of different makeup that you have
to put the actors in sometimes you have
to find a different set so it's all a
question of finding budget for that
because it'd be awesome to see them go
to gorilla City on earth too but it's so
expensive to do all those CG apes you
just can't do them every single episode
but yeah I totally think that we're
gonna see a version of gorilla city
budget pending for how big that episode
ends up being but typically they save
stuff like that for really big episodes
so just as a reminder the flash is
coming back the first week in October
first Tuesday in October it's like the
tip of the spear arrow comes back then
Supergirl starts the week after that
they actually just got Lynda Carter they
got Wonder Woman she's gonna play the
President of the United States I don't
know how many episodes she's gonna be in
but Wonder Woman is going to be the
president of supergirls Earth that's
gonna be so much fun and then later also
that second week in October legends of
tomorrow season 2 starts with all those
Justice Society characters with vixen
that's like a whole other story because
it's gonna look so different from season
1 it'll almost be like a totally
different show so when they get closer
to that I'll explain a little bit more
but until they announce the rest of the
cast until they post a trailer there's
just a lot more questions than we have
for like the flash but the other really
cool thing about the flash just you guys
you guys hyped up for the season is that
they get ready to film really soon Grant
Gustin said that he would be
seeing a ton of stuff from the set when
he gets breaks so we'll see a lot more
stuff from behind the scenes as they're
making episodes than we did in previous
seasons so Wonder Woman is coming to
Supergirl Grant Gustin is gonna post the
at a flashpoint as they film it and
there's a whole bunch of vigilantes
coming to arrow I almost forgot
Artemis is going to be coming to arrow
but it's the person you saw last season
who was wearing the Black Canary outfit
after Laurel had died so the way they
explained it is that that was her trying
to take the mantle of Black Canary but
that proved unsuccessful for her like
within the context of the show so she
has decided to take the mantle of
Artemis and even though her backstory is
different from Artemis in the comics or
even if you watched Young Justice
Sportsmaster and tigress are her parents
in the comics and on Young Justice
that's not going to be the case on the
TV show but I love the idea of
Sportsmaster wearing a hockey mask and
then the wild dog character on arrow
wearing a hockey mask so it'll be a
little meta but season 5 of arrow is
basically going to be city of vigilantes
vs. Oliver Queen not all of them will be
bad though like Artemis is a good
character so like team arrow has
fractured and all these new characters
are coming in that Oliver is gonna have
to deal with and learn to train or take
down if they get out of hand so a lot of
exciting stuff happening and for those
of you that are asking about live-action
young justice because they have a lot of
those characters in the TV universe
already now I totally think they could
do that but they probably wouldn't try
to do that till arrow and flash like
slowly closed down their runs you get
the idea like they have enough
characters that they could do any number
of spin-offs that they want they could
do Teen Titans that they wanted to but
what's gonna happen next is I'll post my
Game of Thrones Q&A video and for those
of you that are going to VidCon this
week I will be at VidCon this weekend so
if you do see me feel free to say hi
give me a high five
anything is totally cool so I will see
you guys at VidCon in there actually
there's a new round of the giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video I'll just announce the winner the
next time I post a DC video so there'll
be new rebirth stuff happening later
this week when you guys wait for my next
video to post you can click here to
learn all about Justice League in the
movie version of the flash and you can
click here for my Game of Thrones finale
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight